salut à tous bienvenue au parlement
européen ici à bruxelles c'est parti
pour 30 minutes d'actualité européenne
dans cette émission je vous emmène au
portugal depuis quelques mois le pays
renoue avec la croissance mais le taux
de chômage et la pauvreté sont toujours
le quotidien des portugais alors reprise
en demi teinte
nous en débattrons mais d'abord
l'actualité après sa réélection voilà
que cette blatter président de la fifa
démissionne il faut dire que les
scandales de corruption se suivent et se
ressemblent alors à quand l'opération
mains propres dans le ballon rond
internationale c'est la question de la
semaine
coup de semonce ce coup de filet dans le
football mondial perquisition au siège
de la concacaf la confédération
américaine de football corruption racket
blanchiment les chefs d'inculpation sont
sévères pour les neuf élus de la fifa et
cinq partenaires de l'instance mondiale
de football
150 millions de dollars de pots-de-vin
et rétro commissions auraient été reçues
et distribué depuis 91 notamment pour
des droits de diffusion de tournois
internationaux
une paille et ce n'est qu'une des bus
selon le procureur fédéral de new york
quelques jours avant le nouveau sacre de
joseph blatter monarque du ballon rond
depuis déjà quatre mandats ça fait
désordre non
même le discret michel platini patron de
l'uefa a mis les pieds dans le plat
nous avons veillé ensemble nous avons
travaillé ensemble
aujourd'hui je viens te demander de
quitter la fifa de démissionner de la
fifa de partir de la fifa parce que
l'image est mauvaise on peut plus
continuer comme ça mais ce qui est beau
avec le football et la fifa c'est qu'à
la fin malgré le dos les et les appels à
la démission
c'est cette qui gagne
malgré un deuxième tour le parrain a
entamé son cinquième mandat
à 79 ans avant de démissionner à la
surprise générale alors à quand
l'opération mains propres dans la
planète football
à quand l'opération mains propres dans
la planète football ça c'est une
question que j'ai posée à marc tarabella
bonjour je vous ai déniché socialiste
démocrate belge et surtout président
qu'au président de l'intergroupe store
ici au parlement européen
bon vous êtes plutôt content que cp
démissionner c'est un premier pas dans
la bonne direction et donc clairement il
a compris que c'était intenable sa
position avec tous les scandales qui ont
et qui éclabousse le football en général
et en particulier depuis depuis très
longtemps dans les attributions de coupe
du monde la coupe très discutée à juste
titre au qatar en 2022
d'où je le rappelle on jouera sur un
charnier puisqu'il a déjà 1200 morts
pour les chanter la coupe du monde ou à
5000 syriens le change là bas donc cette
coupe n'a aucun sens 1200 morts je le
rappelle juste et les conditions de
travail dans la construction des stades
et d'esclavagisme au 21ème siècle
plusieurs entreprises européennes
d'ailleurs sont concernés vinci entre
autres oui c'est très probable mais donc
c'est inacceptable mais les coupes du
monde qui ont été attribuées de manière
illicite le récit qatar afrique du sud
s'est passé puisqu'on sait que jésus est
donc clairement depuis celle platini a
raison il devait partir parce que
l'image est mauvaise mais ça ne suffit
pas que blatter s'en aille il faut une
nouvelle gouvernance à la fifa il faut
de nouvelles règles car il ya un comité
exécutif
blatter n'est pas seul il ya pas mal de
gens qui ont soutenu par les
confédérations effectivement des états
unis mais afrique asie beaucoup beaucoup
afrique et asie et donc effectivement
une fédération une voix
il est clair que les comores par rapport
par exemple l'amérique du sud qui pèse
10 voix sur 209 alors qu'elle a gagné
neuf coupes du monde là l'amérique du
sud l'amérique du sud
il est clair qu'il ya un rééquilibrage à
faire mais c'est surtout dans le mode de
gouvernance qui doit être plus
collégiale par exemple le mode
d'attribution hills au parlement
européen organisera le 29 septembre avec
la fifa avec l'uefa avec le comité
international olympique
une grande séance d'information et de
discussion débat sur les critères
d'attribution des futures compétitions
sportives plus tenir compte de
l'environnement du des conditions
sociales effectivement responsabilité
sociale et environnementale
des grandes opérations est ce qu on sait
que russie 2018
qatar 2022 vous venez d'en parler on
annule on fait quoi
il est clair que l'attribution a été
fait de manière illicite avec corruption
etc
il est très probable qu'il faille revoir
il n'est pas trop tard pour revoir jeudi
18 par exemple la russie 2018 là aussi
je souligne que la douma a voté des lois
qui sont restrictives en matière de
droits des travailleurs bon là
effectivement elle attribue à la russie
s'était moins saugrenue qu'au qatar
parce que le pc du un pays de football
évidemment de très clairement oui et là
mais on essaie reconnaît on connaît
l'envi et effectivement du qatar
d'investir sur ces questions enfin on
connaît dean sport etc
on connaît le rachat du paris
saint-germain en france mais est ce que
pour autant il faut tout enrayée et
essayer bas peut-être le politique
assauts politique en fait de mettre en
place une meilleure gouvernance très
clairement mais par rapport aux coupes
du monde déjà attribués
si elles ont été au prix de corruption
il est possible de réattribuer oui même
si les contrats ont déjà été signés mois
avec le qatar je me focalise sur le
qatar par rapport aux conditions
anormales des travailleurs dont je le
répète plus de 1200 morts ont déjà été
enregistrées essentiellement des
népalais des indiens des sri lankais est
donc clairement ils ont il ya eu des
commissions de sur place qui ont dit que
ça allait peut-être changer la kefala là
le droit du travail allait changer
évoluer il faut aller check et si ça ne
change pas effectivement réattribution
car aussi des candidatures ont été lésés
parce que cela l'ont été jeudi au prix
de votre réforme à table et là vous
dites que les dirigeants ses dirigeants
la fifa ont les poches remplies de
dollars et les mains de sang oui un peu
fort quand même nom mais j'assume à
partir de là on fait une désignation qui
concourra à générer comme ça des
milliers de morts sur les chantiers en
tout cas les centaines pour l'instant
plus de 1200 et qu'en même temps on
entend parler de dizaines de millions
d'euros par ci droits tv pour la zone
caraïbes réduit à zéro
et les amis qui en profitent sont les
amis des amis que certaines finales
sinon je vous coupe 1 150 millions de
dollars de pots-de-vin et de
rétrocommissions c'est un chiffre que
j'ai entendus pour attribuer une coupe
du monde il y avait 24 votants il paraît
qu'une valise cela comporte
elle est équivalente les évaluer j'ai
entendu dire ça les gens du monde du
football
un million et demi de dollars est ce
normal non l'image est très mauvaise et
par rapport au football qui doit générer
une envie c'est un rêve pour tous les
deux mais les adolescents lattès en vie
c'est pas l'argent qui nous fait rêver
c'est moi aussi j'ai rêvé de lever un
jour la coupe d'europe au dessus de ma
tête et voir la coupe du monde
des dizaines de millions à rêver de saba
y en a quelques-uns qui arrivent mais le
football fait rêver et doit continuer à
faire rêver et le sport génèrent
normalement des valeurs d'éthique de
respect de l'autorité de l'arbitré
normalement de partage de goût de
l'effort de vérité
on est complètement passé à côté en ce
qui concerne gaza est ce que michel
platini et le speedcell candidate celui
qui part qui en fait tout ça peut être
du passé je pense que michel platini ce
serait un bon candidat et un sans doute
d'autres je pense à luis figo sekisui
fils maintenant ne restons pas non plus
uniquement européen ait pu y avoir un
bon candidat d'ailleurs parce que
blatter venait de là je dirais qu'il est
suivi de l'uefa finalement de l'union
européenne enfin l'union européenne
ces paroles européen il n'y a pas
d'exclusive il faut peut-être aussi
ailleurs à mon avis ce sera très ouvert
mais l'important c'est que ce soit un
personnage me semble-t-il qui est un
carré m
platini a du charisme c'est un
personnage charismatique qui veuille
dire quelque chose qui est acquis qui
connaît le football parce qu'il a été
évidemment quelqu'un de d'exceptionnel
où dans le monde du football et qui est
un secrétaire général à côté qui soit
celui qui effectivement fait le boulot
de manière propre de manière de manière
licite
ouais transparente et clairement et qui
instaure vraiment un vrai régime
démocratique à la fifa ce dont elle a
besoin elle est devenue une dictature
oui alors il ya autre chose n'y a pas
que la fifa vous avez
vous avez il ya quelques jours mis en
avant que de très lourds soupçons pèsent
sur plus de 50 matches de football
européen pour la saison 2014 2015
notamment sur les championnats italiens
espagnols belges grecs des matches de
l'europa league pour des soupçons de
corruption aussi d'où vous tenez ces
informations eh bien c'est la troisième
fois que j'organise ce type de
rencontres au parlement européen avec
notamment la fédération des entreprises
paris en ligne comment peuvent-ils
détecter qu'un match est très
probablement a été truquée a été arrangé
c'est uniquement par la masse d'argent
qui est parier sur ce match
c'est des sommes incroyables c'est le
son incroyable par exemple pour un match
de division 2 belge
c'est à peu près 10 millions d'euros qui
est parié pour la division 2 belge mais
c'est parfois le bout du monde pour la
d1 francs fin là la première division
française notamment l'alliance et 200
millions d'euros de mises ces 500 en
espagne 1000 en angleterre 300 en italie
300 en allemagne donc 1000 ça veut dire
un milliard d'euros parier sur un match
en match de la première league anglaise
et là vous parler clairement de sommes
d'origine criminelle du blanchiment et
de la corruption donc deux choses
d'abord les matches truqués ces cantons
ont fait la corrélation entre un montant
anormal de paris très élevé sur un score
d'un seul match et que le score à la fin
est celui qui a été parié par un
ensemble d'appareils dont le montant est
anormalement élevé
généralement ce sont les matches de
divisions inférieures qui sont les plus
concernés car moi saint-jean - il ya
moins de caméras autour du terrain
les nordistes ont chacune deux claques
de pays de la ligue pro est donc
clairement c'est plutôt les divisions
inférieures et évidemment c'est un
phénomène qu'il faut essayer de
contrecarrer et là je crois que tout le
monde doit y mettre du sien
grâce à ces informations je pense que
les fédérations sportives doivent
beaucoup plus suivre de presse l'a
encouragé à la prévention aussi comme le
fait la ligue espagnole les joueurs pour
que ça n'arrive pas parce que les
joueurs parfois sont un peu faibles ils
peuvent être approchés par quelqu'un de
délits site et donc l'appât du gain peut
être peut être une motivation est donc
il ya toute une série de jeux d'hier des
dispositifs à mettre en place la justice
avait décidé de déposer plainte fin mais
moi pas procureur je ne suis que des
buteurs c'est pas mal donc je me limite
à mon rôle de donner connaissance de
cela grâce à des outils attend la
fédération des entreprises de paris en
ligne va déposer plainte va informer les
différentes fédérations des pays où ça
s'est passé
en espérant qu'elles suivent et quelles
qu'elles soient actives à cet égard là
il faut aussi au niveau européen sans
doute faire en sorte que je m'en
tiendrais avec le le commissaire aux
sports mais ce cadre à 6 essayer d'avoir
une législation qui soit un peu la même
partout encore de brut mais qu'ils
fassent qu'on punisse sévèrement de la
même manière les avantages de match
partout en europe
ce serait quand même un pas en avant
dans la bonne direction c'est bon
écoutez je retiens que vous votez
platini ou figo de choeur oui parce que
platini aurait pu jouer à l'inter de
milan qui est aussi le club de mon coeur
bon bah écoute et merci beaucoup marc
tarabella de façon on suivra ce dossier
nous on continue et on va direction le
portugal
en 2011 le pays avait obtenu un prêt
international via la troïka de 78
milliards d'euros
la contrepartie une cure de rigueur
drastique depuis quelques mois
maintenant lisbonne la bonne élève
affiche un retour à la croissance est
bons résultats économiques mais à quel
prix c'est un reportage de sandra et
mounir souci
non
ça se passe bien oui ça va être une
expérience intéressante on accueille
aujourd'hui huit nouvelles personnes qui
sont en ce moment en train d'être formés
et demain lui nouveaux salariés nous
rejoindront nous sommes dans une bonne
dynamique
en six mois cette entreprise spécialisée
dans les nouvelles technologies a doublé
ses effectifs
parmi eux lucas au chômage depuis la fin
de ses études son poste n'a rien à voir
avec sa formation mais il n'avait pas le
choix je n'avais pas du tout anticipé
les difficultés qui m'attendait ça a été
un choc de devoir renoncer à mon diplôme
en sociologie pour me réorienter dans un
domaine qui m'était totalement inconnu
celui des nouvelles technologies du web
on dit que c'est une filière d'avenir et
j'ai besoin de travailler
alors j'ai bien dû me rendre à
l'évidence la plupart des personnes
embauchées ici sont des chômeurs de
longue durée
le gouvernement portugais a fait de
cette catégorie une priorité il a mis en
place des aides pour faciliter leur
recrutement
sans elle l'entreprise n'aurait jamais
pu embaucher si vite que les entreprises
profitent actuellement davantage fiscaux
presque cinq fois supérieur quand elles
embauchent des contrats de longue durée
nous avons besoin de beaucoup de monde
cela nous aide à rester compétitifs sur
le marché international
le code du travail portugais a
profondément été réformé il est plus
facile d'embaucher plus facile de
licencier aussi cela coûte moins cher
aux entreprises grâce à cette
flexibilité dont nous bénéficions depuis
trois quatre ans nous pouvons nous
adapter à l'évolution du volume
d'activité qui varie en fonction du
nombre de projets ainsi nous restons
réactif et nous pouvons répondre aux
besoins réels de nos clients à chaque
mois
fou
au portugal le taux de chômage a
commencé à baisser il y a deux ans il
est passé de 17,5 à 14%
car la reprise est là la commission
européenne prévoit une croissance de 1,6
pour cent cette année
c'est mieux que la moyenne de la zone
euro l'économie portugaise est sortie de
la récession les exportations se portent
mieux
mais la reprise reste quand même fragile
et le taux de chômage aurait tendance à
remonter désormais avec une plus grande
flexibilité
beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont sur des
marchés qui ont des croissances rapide
prennent plus de risques et embauchent
plus mais elles licencient aussi plus
facilement
donc cela ne fait pas baisser le chômage
de façon durable
le coût humain de l'austérité reste
énorme
les écarts sociaux continuent de se
creuser malgré la reprise économique
les salaires y compris les moins élevés
continuent de baisser et les droits des
chômeurs ont été fortement réduits au
portugal il faut travailler au moins un
an pour avoir droit à des indemnisations
sinon on ne touche aucune aide une
grande précarité c'est aussi ça la
réalité du pays
un manque de perspective qui pousse
certains à quitter le pays
catharines a enchaîné les contrats
courts pendant des années elle est
infirmière et n'a jamais pu trouver de
travail durable ainsi que ça joue pas
les crises des cantons vous propose des
contrats de 15 jours d'un mois payés
parfois trois ou quatre euros de l'heure
comment vivre avec ça on ne vit pas on
survit
tout augmente le pouvoir d'achat est
toujours plus faible on s'en sort pas il
n'y a que les politiques pour dire que
ça va mieux quand ils disent que
l'austérité derrière nous c'est
complètement faux enfin cette mère de
famille de 40 ans assure que rien n'a
changé pour elle depuis le départ de la
troïka sans espoir elle a décidé de
quitter le pays pour l'angleterre
on a de plus en plus de pères et de
mères de famille de 40 50 ans qui
émigrent pas seulement des jeunes
diplômés loin de là à l'étranger au
moins on trouve du travail correspondant
à un haut niveau d'études et on est payé
à notre juste valeur
il n'y a qu'en quittant le pays
malheureusement qu'on peut avoir des
opportunités d'évolution
jeremic est parti il ya un nom sans
aucune expérience au royaume uni il a
déjà très bien évoluer dans sa carrière
quarante pour cent de la population
active se dit aujourd'hui prête à
quitter le portugal
le deuxième pays d'europe dont la
population et migre le plus
donc à une reprise en demi teinte pour
le portugal à l'heure où on parle encore
et encore du plan de relance grecque et
des négociations pour en parler c'est
nathalie griesbeck que je reçois bonjour
bonjour vous êtes députée française
membre du groupe libéral démocrate et
josé manuel fernandes bonjour je vous
êtes député membre du parti populaire
européen et vous êtes portugal je me
tourne vers vous josé manuel est ce que
c'est une véritable relance ou est-ce
que fondamentalement on voit bien qu'il
ya quand même encore quelques écueils
dont il va falloir sortir
c'est une véritable relance si on
regarde tous les chiffres on peut dire
que on est sorti de la crise le pire est
parti et maintenant par exemple si on
prend les chiffres du chômage on avait
18 % quand on est entré en presque
faillite
maintenant on a 13 oui il est tout l'été
les moins tous les mois
ça diminue les sens si on regarde la
hollande devrait prendre exemple sur
vous c'est ça on soit hollande
il peut nous nous regarde et on a fait
un effort les familles portugaises les
entreprises portugaises
ils ont fait on a fait un effort brutal
brutale brutal mais ça a donné une une
bonne sortie
tout le monde disait tout le monde
disait que c'était impossible de sortir
101 un autre programme
la troïka devrait continuer non on a
sorti et maintenant on a des taux
d'intérêt qui sont très bas pour la
première fois dans notre système est
revenu sur les marchés on est revenu sur
les roches aurait marché mais on a des
taux d'intérêt pas seulement bah comme
même négatif ce qui a été fait ce qui
n'existait pas dans l'histoire du
portugal même avant alors le soir pour
la première fois dans notre histoire de
notre démocratie
on a un déficit qui est inférieur à 3%
ouais en 2019 on va avoir un surplus
budgétaire est quand même
on a fait des choses que personne
s'aperçoit on a augmenté le salaire
minimum on a deux on a augmenté les
retraites le plus beau mais ça elle prit
sa et de josé manuel vous avez quand
même
enfin on parle quand même du premier
ministre portugais sur place parce que
c'est ce qu'on nous a dit comme
de la fin du de la langue est la mère
qu'elle portugaise quoi c'est quand même
des mots un peu fort et quand on voit
qu'il ya un portugais sur cinq sous le
seuil de pauvreté
il ya quand même de quoi se poser des
questions nathalie griesbeck il ya un
mois j'aurais du mal à jeter la pierre
parce que je suis française et que la
situation de mon pays n'est pas facile
tous les jours on va dire et c'est vrai
que le reportage montrait très bien qui
a toute une série de très bons chiffres
à la suite donc de la reprise en main
notamment vous l'avez dit sur le sur le
déficit et même la dette qui baissent un
petit peu mais le reportage le montre on
voit bien que c'est embellir
elle est en demi-teinte parce que 1
certainement oui de s'apprécier un
portugais et on continue d'avoir envie
de partir et moi je vois je suis de la
région s de la france il ya une très
grosse communauté à l'uso fans enfin et
je discute beaucoup
et là la chose dont il parle tout de
suite parce que leurs familles restées
au pays et ils nous retournerons pour
vivre leur retraite ils disent beaucoup
que c'est très difficile avec donc des
des revenus des ressources mensuelles
qui sont très basses même à autre quand
même dans la mesure est loin de 400
euros par mois un portugais sur cinq vit
avec moins de 400 aujourd'hui ça paraît
plus de 500 je crois que les minimes m
minimum et les cinq sens voilà le
salaire minimum mais moi j'ai pas du
seuil de pauvreté
oui il faut voir que le seuil de
pauvreté en europe c est moins de 60% du
revenu moyen sur mesure on avait un état
membre où le revenu moyen c'était dix
mille euros poids par mois
si quelqu'un gagner 5000 euros par mois
il était en vie mais il était en
situation euros par mois je vous mets au
défi de vivre avec 400
je suis pas en train de contester cela
je suis en train de dire que et c'est
bien en europe on a une définition de de
pauvreté wiki ambitieuse et elle est
bien au portugal bien sûr que on doit
augmenter aussi si possible et quand
possible et on l'a fait par exemple le
salaire minimum on a des aides pour les
faits les familles plus pauvres et on a
aussi des associations des institutions
de solidarité sociale qui auront fait un
grand travail justement sur ces mesures
dette sociale quand on voit que pendant
un an
à défaut d'avoir un contrat d'un an les
chômeurs ne sont pas indemnisés on voit
bien que ça pousse aussi à la grande
pauvreté
on a même des taux de retrait de l'école
obligatoire qui est un des plus
importants d'europe 1 oui on voit bien
qu'il ya aussi un risque de fuite des
cerveaux de disparition d'une partie de
la jeunesse qui décide de jeter l'épongé
et de partir tenter sa chance ailleurs
alors que la situation personnellement
je trouve que la situation au portugal
ll est marqué par cette embellie est
donc il faut tout faire pour que les
portugais est en vie de de doper leur
pays mariam de 31 pour mel est jaunâtre
voilà pour les jeunes je pense que là il
ya des possibilités avec l'initiative
pour l'emploi des jeunes le qe1 et ça il
faut l'utiliser c'est un milliard qui a
été débloqué ici en europe mais je crois
que pour le portugal je crois que c'est
50 millions pour cette année 2015 pour
essayer de deûle et de les aider et puis
moi je plaide beaucoup et je ne sais pas
ce qu'en pense mon collègue je me plais
beaucoup pour l'idée d'apprentissage
européen c'est à dire des jeunes qui
sont soit sorti de l'école son
information soit avec une formation à la
mobylette le pied à l'étrier leur
proposer une mobilité européenne et
l'associer avec l'initiative pour
l'emploi des jeunes ça permettrait de
c'est l'idée de faire profiter les porte
aux portugais
l'embellie qui est quand même dans les
chiffres un petit peu alors marqué un
tournant
la garantie jeunesse oui elle a été au
portugal c'est le portugal qui a été le
premier à laval à faire j'ai travaillé
ici au parlement avec la sueur john
harris notamment pour la mobilité des
jeunes
on utilise le portugal est en train de
sortir les exportations augmentent la
balance commerciale elle est plus
équilibré que je que jamais on a une
teinte au de croissance supérieur à
celui de la zone euro bien sûr que nous
sommes un pays mind et avec mes qualités
de vie josé problème le problème
je vais vous couper parce que on va on
va avancer justement sur cette question
en parlant de mobilité il y avait
justement christine sur cette question
de chute des cerveaux y avait une
question directe à vous poser je
voudrais qu'on écoute
il ya toujours plus de gens qui ont faim
d'enfants qui vont à l'école sans manger
finissent aux urgences c'est ça la
réalité portugaise pas la croissance
économique
l'europe nous tue à petits feux en grèce
aussi
l'ubs continue d'imposer la poursuite de
l'austérité comment est ce que c'est
possible
combien de preuves faudra-t-il pour
montrer que c'est une fausse route
josé manuel fernandes christine a décidé
de quitter le pays
comme elle il ya quasiment deux millions
de portugais qui sont en dehors et
notamment des gens qui ont 40 50 ans ce
qui est un petit peu inédit un
finalement pour le portugal s'était
jusque là plutôt des jeunes on fait quoi
pour retenir ces populations est ce que
c'est pas une fuite des cerveaux
une saignée pour l'économie portugaise
si on a on doit avoir un enseignement
une éducation qui doit être aussi
d'accord avec le marché sans crise
économique
on a tellement par exemple d'un fermier
et tous les ans ça sort des infirmiers
que c'est impossible qu'il puisse avoir
un emploi au portugal même sans aucune
crise économique et avec une un taux de
croissance est énorme et ça se passe
aussi dans d'autres professions sur la
mobilité elle est très importante pas
seulement pour le portugal et on doit ce
on doit sentir l'europe comme et on doit
renforcer la citoyenneté et rond
européen peut servir ils ont été écoutés
venir de porto à paris venir de porto à
bruxelles venir de porto à londres c'est
plus rapide et des fois beaucoup de fois
moins cher qu'à l'est de porto à
lisbonne et à l'europe
la mobilité est dans l'europe n'est pas
être un problème
elle doit charles doit elle doit être
aussi une mobilité avec c'est un vrai
retour parce que qui fait un erasmus par
exemple là on parle pas des restes mais
ça non mais je
je parle de la mobilité tu fais les
personnes qui ont des expériences de
mobilité
elles reviennent en effet elles elles
sont l on peut c'est plus facile de
reprendre un autre métier au le métier
ils ont fait cette fuite des cerveaux
vous en parliez tout à l'heure il ya
quand même quelque chose de dramatique
pour le pour les pays en qui sont
concernés bien sûr parce que les
citoyens désespère et les relances ou
les embellies sont trop longues à être
visible et est ressentie par les
citoyens alors il ya la jeunesse et les
dispositifs c'est vrai le portugal les
utilisent
mais il ya toute la classe moyenne avec
le problème tout simplement de pouvoir
d'achat je crois que les fonctionnaires
sont aussi en très grande difficulté
donc il faut restaurer la confiance
c'est facile de dire il faut faucon
c'est facile de le dire mais il faut
réussir à la à faire en sorte que les
portugais aient envie de rester et pas
seulement de revenir mais en même temps
il ya beaucoup d'européens qui
s'installe mais sont plutôt des
retraites- y voilà ils viennent parce
que lille a pillé vaut le coup mais ce
sera à redon l'objet d'un autre débat on
pourra se réinviter rendez-vous
tranquillement mois d'octobre sur les
golden globes malheureusement c'est la
fin de notre émission merci à tous les
deux dit avoir participé
nous on se retrouve dans 15 jours la
semaine prochaine c'est katia bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires ciao
on